it's scary what's going on right now um
especially with the uh
the scraping that's of the military and
i don't know if a lot of people know
that this is going on uh but
pretty much ncis uh cid which is the
investig investigatory body for the army
and then osi is the investigatory body
for the air force they're going through
mainly special operators
through all of their social media they
have access to it
and if you have
anything that's uh what they consider
extremist which i consider pro-american
so if you uh are a trump supporter if
you
have pro-american slogans like don't
tread on me stuff like that if you
support the police
they are labeling you as an extremist
and they're putting you into a group
right now so that's happening right now
and then what i see happening is they is
just known is this known everybody knows
that this is happening scraping
no i mean it's being talked about more
recently now i think the news finally
picked it up i i found out about this a
couple months ago from a buddy who
actually saw it happening uh
and so what they'll do what i think
they'll do is once they label you an
extremist it's against the uniform code
of military justice to be part of an
extremist group or a gang or anything so
they will just
you know legally kick you out of the
military
i mean long term this is just going to
lower the standards and raise more
pansies than
raise tough leaders that you need to
protect your country i mean it's just
not a
proven formula sometimes you wonder what
their motive is what the outcome of is
doing this
i think that's the scary part is you
have to ask yourself why are they doing
this why are they taking out the one
percent that actually wants to fight for
this country because i'll tell you being
in the military
you learn really quick that whatever
administration is in charge and whatever
their agenda is it trickles down to you
like you get you see little bits and
pieces of it
but uh
we learn to sort of just
deal with those and work our way around
them so we can continue fighting the
enemy right we don't care
i i wasn't political at all when i was
in the military i was just i'll do what
i'm told i just want to go fight for
this country right
well now they're getting rid of those
people with that mentality they're going
after those people and so it's like well
who's going to be left then who's
fighting for them who is fighting for
them who's fighting for you guys
i don't at this point i don't know i
mean that's why i'm about getting the
word out so people people do understand
what's going on and people will speak up
is it is there a high ranking person
that's pretty vocal to go up against
that uh uh
passivistication of you know whatever to
make everybody softer who's who's
pushing back
you see what happens to high ranking
officials when they do speak out and
push back
you just that you talk to the space
force commander i mean
they are pretty much done away with
and that's why and that's the big fear
tactic as well they they
you speak out they'll be like we'll get
rid of you so everyone keeps their mouth
shut so they can keep their job
you know who i think we need to bring
back
i think we need to bring back what was
his name what was uh al pacino's name
and scent of a woman that lieutenant
remember what i'm talking about
who are
and he called out the entire school we
almost need somebody like that with
audacity to go out there and just keep
kicking their asses
to uh let the world know what to take
what it takes to be you so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]